Build It.
Draw It.
Play It.
Vsauce!
Kevin here!
With some of the coolest creations from extraordinary
people.
This is BiDiPi.
BUILD IT
Sebastian Huber, Robert Pohle and Johannes
Timpernagel built an interactive framework
that transforms a user and the surroundings
into a system of particles.
With audio by Berlin-based Kling Klang Klong
- the body movements trigger sounds as well
as visuals and the motion-tracking is done
with Xbox Kinect.
Carol Milne knits with glass.
She created a technique of knitting strands
of wax together and then encases the sculpture
in refractory mold material into which she
pours molten glass.
And she wishes for her work to be viewed as
a metaphor for social structure.
As individual strands are weak and brittle
on their own, but deceptively strong when
bound together.
Zollner Elektronik AG has built a giant robot
dragon.
It's the current record holder for the world's
largest robot, measuring in at 51 ft long,
40 ft wide, and 26 ft 10 in (8high.
It can walk, breath fire, and is controlled
via a remote.
It has been displayed in fairs and plays all
around Germany.
DRAW IT
Martín Feijoó brings cloud shapes to life.
He takes pictures of suggestively shaped clouds
and illustrates them with the first thing
that comes to mind.
As a child he was told that clouds’ shapes
were created by balloon-twisting clowns that
live in the sky and this project is an exploration
of that memory.
Eric Standley uses lasers to cut intricate
designs into hundreds of sheets of paper.
Each piece takes months of drawing and planning,
and his overarching goal has been to recreate
the majesty and scale of Gothic and Islamic
architecture and then bring it into a considerably
smaller space.
And now for the art of Scott Listfield featuring
an astronaut that explores pop culture and
the present.
Mary Doodles combines her love of drawing
with her passion for improv.
On her YouTube show titled “What will I
draw?!”
she turns scribbles into fully realized works
of art, such as an assassin, a Swamp Witch,
or a dying dragon.
PLAY IT
STARY OLSA uses period authentic replicas
of age-old Belarusian instruments to accurately
recreate medieval music - and here’s their
version of Metallica’s One.
Chemical Legs by Com Truise features an industrial
vibe combined with sounds from 80’s video
games and here he is showing off his hands-on
synth skills at Room 205.
Finally, 'Me gusta que me pegues' by LOS PUNSETES
features a human pinata and was directed by
Barcelona-based production company Canada.
Inspiration also comes from you - Vsauce creative
fan showcase.
First up is Make Acid with Power Bomb - let’s
go!
David Loyola make papercut desk ornaments
using an Xacto knife, paper, wood, glass and
plenty of patience.
Donny Phillips lasercuts vinyl records into
portraits of rock stars including David Bowie,
Morrissey and Tom Waits.
Neventual created this glowing animation for
a song by Jacoo.
Fienix create custom snapback hats with handmade
bills.
Based in Los Angeles, they have an Etsy shop
where they sell their one of a kind hats.
Odd Arne Roll made a virtual reality LEGO
helmet using a smartphone with a 3D app and
some inexpensive lenses.
Xicheng Xu made a gesture-controlled robotic
arm.
And now the graphic design of Chris Halderman
Submit your BiDiPis to BiDiPi@Vsauce.com or
share them with everyone on Twitter using
the hashtag #BiDiPi.
And as always - thanks for watching!